>>> WE'RE BK WITH OUR WORLDLY
PRESIDENT BIDEN HOSTING FRENCH
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON TODAY
FOR HIS FIRST STATE VISIT SINCE
MOVING INTO THE WEST WING.
THE TWO SAY THEY DISCUSSED THE
RUSSIAN INVASION OF UKRAINE AT
LENGTH, AND HOW TO FURTHER
SUPPORT THE UKRAINIANS FIGHTING
BACK AGAINST PUTIN.
AS CNN'S PHIL MATTINGLY REPORTS
FOR US NOW, PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS
HE IS WILLING TO MEET WITH
PUTIN, BUT ONLY UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> Reporter: ON A DAY CAREFULLY
CALIBRATED TO ELEVATE A CRITICAL
ALLIANCE.
>> MR. PUTIN IS, CHOOSE MY WORDS
VERY CAREFULLY.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN
SINGLING A WILLINGNESS TO OPEN A
LINE OF COMMUNICATION WITH
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
>> I'M PREPARED TO SPEAK WITH
MR. PUTIN, IF, IN FACT, THERE IS
AN INTERESTING IN HIM DECIDING
HE'S LOOKING FOR A WAY TO END
THE WAR.
>> Reporter: WITH CLEAR
PRECONDITIONS.
>> HE HASN'T DONE THAT YET.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, IN
CONSULTATION WITH MY FRENCH AND
NATO FRIENDS, I'LL BE HAPPY TO
SIT DOWN WITH PUTIN TO SEE WHAT
HE WANTS -- HAS IN MIND.
HE HASN'T DONE THAT YET.
>> Reporter: THE BRUTAL WAR IN
ITS NINTH MONTH AT THE CENTER OF
A THREE-HOUR SIT DOWN EMMANUEL
MACRON.
AFTER WARDS, MA --
>> WE WILL NEVER URGE THE
UKRAINIANS TO MAKE A COMPROMISE
THAT WILL NOT BE ACCEPTABLE TO
THEM.
>> Reporter: BIDEN'S FIRST STATE
VISIT UNDERSCORED, THE VALUE AND
DURABILITY WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
SEE WITH AMERICA'S LONGEST
RUNNING ALLY, WITH TWO LEADERS
GOING TO GREAT LENGTHS TO
DEMONSTRATE THEIR UNITY, AND
IRON OUT CLEAR CUT DIFFERENCES.
>> I MAKE NO APOLOGY.
>> Reporter: BIDEN LOOKING TO
ADDRESS FRENCH CONCERNS WITH
SWEEPING SUBSIDIES IN CORNER
STONE WITH HIS CLIMATE
LEGISLATION.
>> THERE ARE OCCASIONS WHEN YOU
WRITE A MASSIVE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION, AND THAT HAS ALMOST
$368 BILLION FOR THE LARGEST
INVESTMENT IN CLIMATE CHANGE ON
ALL OF HISTORY.
AND SO THERE'S OBVIOUSLY GOING
TO BE GLITCHES IN IT.
>> Reporter: AND PROVIDING
ASSURANCES THAT ISSUE WOULD BE
ADDRESSED.
>> I'M CONFIDENT.
THAT'S MY ANSWER.
>> Reporter: FOR MACRON, A DAY
AND A DINNER UNDERSCORING A
WHITE HOUSE VIEW OF A
RELATIONSHIP THAT HAS ONLY GROWN
IN ITS IMPORTANCE IN BIDEN'S
FIRST TWO YEARS, ONE DRIVEN,
OFFICIALS SAY, BY A GENUINE
PERSONAL CONNECTION.
>> I BEGAN TO REFER TO HIM
PRIVATELY AS MY CLOSER.
>> Reporter: A CONNECTION THAT
HAS BECOME CRITICAL IN A MOMENT
WHEN THREATS HAVE RATTLED
ALLIANCES WORLDWIDE.
>> FRANCE SOMEONE OF OUR
STRONGEST PARTNERS AND
HISTORICALLY, BUT ONE OF OUR
STRONGEST PARTNERS AND MOST
CAPABLE ALLIES, AND EMANUEL HAS
ALSO BECOME A FRIEND IN ADDITION
TO BEING THE PRESIDENT OF THAT
GREAT COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: JAKE, THAT
THREE-HOUR MEETING BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS CERTAINLY AT THE CENTER OF
THE VISIT, BUT OBVIOUSLY THE
MAIN EVENT IS THE DINNER IN JUST
A COUPLE OF HOURS, SEVERAL
HUNDRED GUESTS ARE EXPECTED TO
ARRIVE FOR THE FIRST STATE
DINNER FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN,
THERE WILL BE DANCING.
THERE WILL BE DINNER A REAL
COMINGLING OF FRENCH AND
AMERICAN TRADITIONS AND COLORS.
JOHN BAPTISTE, IS SCHEDULED TO
PERFORM.
>> THERE'S A CONTROVERSIAL ABOUT
ONE OF THE MAIN DISHES BEING
SERVED AT THE STATE DINNER, TELL
US ABOUT THAT.
>> Reporter: MAIN DISH, IT'S
LOBSTER.
200 LIVE LOBSTERS SENT DOWN FROM
THE STATE OF MAINE, YOU WOULD
THINK IT WOULD THRILL MAINE
POLITICIANS.
IT'S AT THE CENTER OF A
REGULATORY AND LEGISLATIVE
BATTLE ONGOING FOR SOME TIME
FROM CONSERVATIONISTS WHO WOULD
LIKE THE LOBSTER MEN TO STOP
GETTING THE LOBSTERS THEY DO.
THERE'S FRUSTRATION THAT
REGULATORY ACTIONS BY THE
ADMINISTRATION RUN COUNTER TO
THE IDEA OF WANTING TO SUPPORT
OR BRING DOWN THOSE LOBSTERS.
AS FOR THE MOMENT, OFFICIALS
AREN'T WEIGHING IN ON THE
MATTER, BUT MAINE POLITICIANS
MAKING IT CLEAR, IF IT'S GOOD
ENOUGH FOR THE WHITE HOUSE, IT
SHOULD BE GOOD ENOUGH FOR ANY
GROCERY STORE OR CERTAINLY
REGULATORS.
>> CONGRESSMAN